let's make some goddamn spaghetti that's
right my name is PewDiePie and I'm on a
mission to make spaghetti in a cooking
simulator I have not played this game
before so I don't even know if it's
possible that's how committed I am to
this spaghetti making spaghetti is one
of those few things that I actually know
how to cook how does it work
oh it's a blender okay all right
spaghetti is one of those few things
that I actually know how to cook the lie
detector determined that was a lot now
the first thing you need to do for a
successful spaghetti is chop the onion
so let's grab them okay let's see how
you do this okay chop
I like onion I don't like the
consistencies I always chop them very
finely which is what we're gonna do here
okay well that's good enough hey maybe I
can use the blender you think I wanted
that work move vertically okay okay okay
drop what's happening do that yeah all
right that doesn't work all right so we
have our onion that one is breaking it
down for some reason oh we can put it in
the food processor put it in gently
gently put it in gently thank you
now now they will be chopped
cool they all disappeared are you
kidding me
alright let's just chop it right here
I'm sick of this I just realize now I
have to pick them all up individually
I'm a goddamn idiot
I need a cutting board unless I can just
scoop them over can I do that can i
scoop no the answer is no for the god
addict for the hundredth time let's make
some onion on this onion cutting you're
actually not supposed to use a wooden
board for cutting onion guess that it
might be a might be it sucks it up okay
and you don't want onion sucked up in
your day shit I'm gonna get a plastic
board for this game sucks so this will
do all right I think we've done it next
we grab a pan everyone laughs we put it
down we turn on the heat let's not
forget the oil avocado water sunflower
red honey when oil
I need cooking oil there it is Oliver
okay perfect open bottle let's pour that
baby or that baby in the bottle
there it is put you down there excellent
well let's get those motherfuckin onions
cool that makes sense
why the fuck is there a shelf there are
you kidding me
it's fine god damn it oh my god let's
put you down all right cool
we're making spaghetti there it is
that's the sound that's the sound I need
a spatula blowtorch
so we have our spatula make sure they
don't get burned let's get the onion and
we're cooking it wrong
there you go can we chop it in the pan
because I would save me a lot of time we
are cooking the knife everyone there it
is there it is where did they go onions
just don't disappear there you go just a
little bit
god dammit I'm doing I'm doing it all
wrong I forgot you okay I need a I need
a deeper Bowl I need a deep bowl can I
get a deep Bowl day a small pot this is
the small pot apparently according to
this game everyone this is how you do I
forgot you don't tell you that you could
yeah
and I would yeah yeah yeah okay and then
yeah yeah yeah he's for it yeah let's
get the onion it's with the onion let's
get the onion let's get them all right
well one two of them made it two of them
made it that's a win can I change the
temperature there's one setting all
right next up and grab the mints cool
there's no mints
there's hamburger meat so I guess we're
doing that I guess through you at three
will do now we want to cook that with a
lid for about are you kidding me
oh it's too hot I can't touch it
where's the rest stick an onion I'll
just grab the fun
and you guys oh you see it getting
cooked
okay okay game we needed tomato sauce
tomato sauce tomato salsa tomato sauce
tomato sauce where are you
liquid they don't have tomato sauce but
they have a ketchup so that's what we're
going fit mmm ketchup in the spaghetti
luxury there you go
I guess we need a lot of it colonic I
poured the whole bottle of hemorrhoids
alright that's starting to look good
maybe we add some spices or oregano
there you go
I'm staying true to the recipe let's not
forget salt this spaghetti is gonna be
the bone pop up here spaghetti and then
some pepper all right now while that is
cooking on low temperature we're gonna
add some water
all right
let's put that on the stove until it
boils
and let's not forget to salt the water
I'm getting good at this you want to let
that simmer a bit and let's make sure
the water boils meanwhile let's get some
pasta okay they don't have spaghetti but
they have penne pasta penne
is it boiling yet is it even on its on
why is it not boiling all right the legs
all right we didn't hit a stick god damn
it
try that again this is basically yeah it
looks like we need more water I'll show
that cover cool kind of place do we you
okay the pen is boiling this is going
great looking really good
maybe try and stir it a little bit make
sure the pasta isn't goddammit don't do
that whoa
why is it spatula oh my god there's one
onion in there it's fine let's just cook
it in red wine then chop the mince maybe
wow you can cut it so nicely amazing
this is going to be the best goddamn uh
spaghetti in the planet there you go
how's the pennant overboiled got it
Thanks
we need a what is it called
the water dispenser utensil cool they
don't have it I guess a fryer basket
would do it
Oh qalander that's what full calendar I
got it I got it I got it done all right
this is a very crucial moment we need to
get the pasta in the colander I don't
see how I can mess this up yeah
get in there my sweet savory children
okay
now let's put the thing in the thing oh
yeah oh yeah we're making art here hey
hey get out of my face turn off you're
annoying me so much
you're wasting water oh I was using the
hot water alright how's my pasta sauce
looking good it's that a banana for no
reason
can you just cook banana alright that
will be our dessert a chocolate that's
what came out I poured a whole liter of
spaghetti sauce that's what came out
I wanted coordinate stop and there you
have it everyone
Bon Appetit there's flank spaghetti now
let's see how this banana mails anything
well shoot what can we add to this to
make it more delicious add some
chocolate
now that's a nice banana that's a good
banana what if we chop it into Michael
are you telling me I can't put my banana
in my microwave maybe I need to put it
on a plate
all we missed all of it
there's my banana microwave that
are you kidding me I crouched hurry up
my bananas dying oh god I don't trust
you but I have no choice
oh my god it works seemingly asleep
there you go
in you go there you go close close let's
microwave
some people say you should microwave
metal oh my god I can't open the door
are you kidding me
spatula please there we go how's my
Burnett it's too hot
god damn off perfect what is this game
oh my god it's stuck
banana come back banana place had some
of their cool stuff like the cool
equipments like what can you do you can
blow torch you should probably be
careful with this oh god damn it that's
bad is that bad
go bucket oh god it's spreading God Emma
are you kidding me
let's get the gasses away from me oh no
not my food ah okay it's fine just need
to grab Dave oh god
Oh God now like this spaghetti you were
like a brother to me spaghetti you were
like a goddamn from ah god damn it
there's not even a piece let cool well
that was a cooking simulator I think it
went pretty well that was my spaghetti
can't try it I don't know if it was good
or not but I think I'm gonna end that
episode there so thank you guys for
watching smash like subscribe and let me
know if you follow this recipe and how
you did thank you
nailed it what you never played super
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price